I moved from the United States to Singapore about two years ago.
One of the most important reasons for my transition was spending more time with my mom.
At that time, I met with my co-founder Lilly as well.
We were going through the same phase of our lives
We would have spent more time with
Our parents and relatives are older.
Our design solution provides excellent home care
To allow for independent living at home.
We thought that Lilly's previous experience could be integrated into healthcare
With my previous experience in business and technology
To provide this improved experience in home care.
When the health of older people worsens
They will not want to go to the hospital
Loss of control over their lives.
They all want to take care of the home.
The Homage application provides access
For people who need care for them and their loved ones.
My work starts at 9 am and ends at 6.30
So my mother will be alone during my working hours.
She told me she could not take care of herself
In things like bathing, dressing and cooking.
"Cali" was selected through Homage as a mother care specialist.
She is very friendly and tells me
"Do not worry, go to your work and take care of it."
"Cali" also took some pictures
To know what I gave my mother
That was very comfortable.
I can tell what happens to my mom anytime and anywhere.
The latest Start on Android software is a big difference in the development of our mobile app.
The program has contributed to our growth and our experience to users.
All the discussions were about
How to improve this experience
Either in a multi-dimensional design, or in UI / UX.
The program was helping us look at the command from a user perspective.
One of the benefits of signing up for the Start On Android program
To show us our apps on the Play Store recently.
It was very nice to get this support not just from the wonderful support team
But also members of a technical community like Google Play.
I recommend that other startups join Start on Android.
Where you will benefit greatly from external comments.
Often you can develop independently
And get expert advice on aspects that need improvement.
It can speed up the way these improvements are offered to users.
We aspire to build a large community of caregivers
Trainers who are happy to help anyone.
Using the Homage application, you'll get help with a single click.
Older people will not worry about aging after knowing that
A helping hand will always protect them.